tim is on the line in New Mexico hey Tim
how are you hey Dave what's going on how
are you sir
better than I deserve man how can I help
uh I was just going to let you know I
just graduated in May and with that I
fortunately got a job but of course got
some debt with that about forty nine
thousand I paid off about seven good six
months right now I've got about a
wedding saved up and with my tax return
I should get about six back or so and
then hopefully a bonus here in April all
right and I was wondering I'm going to
put about you know 25 down on the debt
as soon as I get it all but my company
offers 10% 401k no you don't need you
don't need to be in a 401k right now you
got debt coming out your ears and you
really don't need a big savings account
right now you got debt coming out yours
you need to make this right what about
everything above $1,000 needs to be just
torn into this debt so tax returns
bonuses any cash flow you've got from
anywhere anything above a thousand
dollars in an account everything's
thrown at this debt thrown at this debt
thrown at this debt all right and then
you're going to be done with the debt
very quickly if you do that and yeah I
should be done hopefully by August but I
was despairing yeah now since they match
10% but you don't get them now the focus
is more important than the match on the
short-term you need to if you've got
that complete focus that laser focus
that's what moves the needle otherwise
you're going to wake up in five years
this thing's still going to be lingering
right and so just for a short period of
time
it's I'm not doing nothing except that's
right you know right that's what does it
that's what moves the needle on the debt
more than the math stuff does it's this
passion and this laser focus that's what
pushes people through this and why we've
had such success with this with the baby
steps and with the debt snowball and so
forth you got plenty of time to invest
in you're going to be very wealthy if
you stay on this track okay cuz you're
gonna have 40 years or 30 years to
invest and get the 10% match and stuff
right right you know we're talking about
still August so and by the way are you
did anything change since you got this
tax refund I mean cuz you're you've got
too much coming out of your check
a $6,000 tax refund is the same thing as
$500 a month too much coming out of your
check and so you're giving the
government an interest-free loan you
probably need to change your w-4 so you
get more coming home that's probably
what you need to do hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you are not a victim
you're not a victim of big corporations
you're not a victim of Wall Street
you're not a victim of capitalism you're
not a victim of wealth inequality you're
not a victim of racism you're not a
victim